[Musique]
tous les clients commandent sur notre
site on l'est on leur prépare leur
commandement des ondes est quasi un peu
à l'ancienne comme celui ci
chaque client commande une deux trois
caisses donc là je suis en train de
préparer la la commande d'une cliente
qui habite à chatou j'ai commandé douze
grandes bouteilles pour elle a livré
dans une caisse comme celle ci nous on a
une application mobile pour pouvoir
préparer toutes ses commandes cette
clientèle a commandé 6 7 6 pétillante
donc mcdo qui vient des vosges
pour ce palier d'envoyer vous avez un
pack d'eau donc six bouteilles d'eau
quelques jus et une bouteille de vin ça
c'est un panier qui entre 25 et 30 euros
julia
est donc le véhicule a chargé toute la
nuit j'arrive à suffisamment de
batteries pour la tournée à venir nous
notre objectif c'est que les gens il
puisse diminuer leur impact justement en
passant à la consigne donc on a voulu
être cohérent et est utilisé une flotte
de véhicules uniquement électrique pour
minimiser l'impact de la livraison
si maintenant on peut partir en tournée
c'est bon les gars
on est parti on va vers notre premier
point de tourner cawi donc ça à 15
minutes là de notre entrepôt le client
va recevoir un texto en lui disant
la tournée passe dans x minutes on s'est
également calculé automatiquement et
donc le client va savoir un peu pour se
préparer ou alors pour mettre sa caisse
devant chez lui si s'il a juste envie
qu'on fasse les changes sur le pas de sa
porte bonjour c'est la tournée oui
voilà
donc là en fait on a dit ça va ok très
bien je vais récupérer les bouteilles
vides oui et je vais écouter et ça va
être crédité automatiquement
up valider la livraison je mets 10
grandes bouteilles recrédité la consigne
et c'est bon
au revoir
[Musique]
où
à chaque livraison on récupère les
bouteilles vides de la livraison
précédente en fait au moment du passage
de commande des clients payent une
qu'aucune consigne donc ça fonctionne un
peu comme une compte d'une caution et au
moment où on récupère les bouteilles en
fait on va leur recrédité cette consigne
est donc une fois qu'on récupère toutes
ces bouteilles vides on va à l'étrier
dans cette allée là donc là vous voyez
vous avez uniquement des bouteilles
vides on les trie pas référence aux par
fournisseurs et l'idée donc de toutes
ces bouteilles vides c'est que elles
proviennent uniquement de fournisseurs
qui ont un système de réemploi c'est à
dire que c'est des bouteilles qui vont
être lavés et réutilisées aujourd'hui
avec ces premières entrepôts on a pu y
aurait entre les vingt mille bouteilles
notre objectif c'est d'entrer employés
cinq cent mille en 2022 et en espère
être en bonne voie pour cela fait il ya
beaucoup de consommateurs qui sont
sensibilisés au sujet des déchets des
cons pas vraiment de solutions pratiques
à portée de main en fait et puis de
l'autre côté aussi des industriels les
petits producteurs ils ont soit ils ont
envie de battre de proposer des formats
consignés soit ils sont qu'avec la
régulation
qui va être de plus en plus
contraignantes ils vont plus avoir le
choix sauf qu'en fait ils n'ont pas
vraiment de canaux de distribution
adaptée aujourd'hui et nous c'est ça en
fait on a voulu créer avec la tournée
c'est vraiment ce chaînon manquant pour
pouvoir permettre la collecte des
contenants à chaque nouvelle livraison
le but ça va être vraiment de s'étendre
sur toute la grande couronne en
commençant évidemment par par les
yvelines
[Musique]
également le val d'oise où on va ouvrir
une quinzaine de villes le mois prochain
et donc pour vraiment pouvoir livrer
tous les tous les clients en ile de
france
[Musique]